but it's not raining I don't see any
rate less other day
don't bring luggage like Nina has a
question for you Londoners the crazy
similar to pounds prepare shoes anyway
we got them
[Music]
what's up relief nation happy weekend we
are getting off the boat
it's our close the last day of our trip
got a couple more days in London then
we're getting home
the boat was rocking like crazy last
night didn't sleep that well but it's
okay
no more rocking anymore because we're
good enough to boat we get some food and
then head up we're in Southampton which
is what is it 45 minutes for 90 minutes
for Monday 90 minutes Humber train get
into London last breakfast on the cruise
ship gotta make it count
this is round one Nina's house breakfast
see those hashbrowns and we got some
coffee all right bye Nina we're off the
boat that's it no more boat no more
crazy food just London food but no more
five thousand calorie days all right
we shared a cab with some fellow
Canadians are you hiding behind me other
Suns
well maybe Nina's little bit child or
Sonny from the edge of platform one the
approaching train palace station Oh
very sad fortune train is not scheduled
to stop and if we shared a cab with some
Canadians oh it's fine back to London
Starbucks all right
[Music]
all right we made it to London we are
back Nina is
the put the tire she passed out on the
chain
how you feeling some lashes just a
little nauseous see legs
but so much movement on the train
you still wanna get a Starbucks oh
really no okay no no we can keep going
on you got you got a little of you gotta
want it you want it is that firm bold
belief
all right for a full belief let's get a
severance it's Lena Lena shoulders are
hurting so good husband takes the
backpack I got a front pack now I got ah
I got a front pack in the backpack
that's what's up good husband all right
it was supposed to be raining this
morning until about three o'clock and
then be good for tomorrow but it's not
raining I don't see any rain uh bunny
play so pretty exciting good start to
the day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
take it into Westminster Abbey because
they won't let Nina bring in her or
luggage
less other day don't bring luggage
backpacks only no next time we travel
this backpack only look I can even carry
both of them from you okay next I'll
give you a huge backpack oh well if I
had a huge bag I could get into let's
mr. heavy alright next up we're gonna
hop on our bus and hopefully find our
bus and then head to our hotel the drop
off our bags and then continue with our
day we have to go to the bathroom
virginity said we stopped at McDonald's
and decided that we recognize them by
eating here too
this brings back memories because I used
to always only eat in McDonald's when I
travel and since being with me man I
don't like you've gone out once to
McDonald's but but here we are we've
Donald's the flashback see what they
have
so it shows you which ones are being
prepared and who needs to go and collect
on number 67 so I'm still being prepared
all right lunch is served we got french
fries that's normal
we've got cheese bites that's new you
don't know that we've got McFlurry like
plates which is different that a coke
got a I got a Big Mac Nita got a big
taste while you look at your box we're
good in the big match for the difference
Wow Nina's got the big burger she won't
try something new
classic Big Mac I went five sick Nina we
got this
enjoy Nina canyon is taking a bite of
the giant burger with bacon
she's eaten have upside down there it is
I was at big tasty is it tasty which I
wanted the cheese balls cheese bites
this is new for us
mozzarella it's a good all right you
like to faint
I will all right time to eat
all right we're done with the cookies
how you feeling tired sleepy Lina's
crashing we are in Knightsbridge which
is a swanky area of London Nina has
booked us a place here so we're gonna go
find we were gonna be crashing for the
next two nights drop off our stuff maybe
Nina won that
today
all right we dropped off our stuff
feeling better feeling a lot lighter
that was great it's great not having had
the suitcases carrying around double
backpacks truck back next stop we have
to find the shoe store someone that we
know is asking us to buy these shoes
that are only in London that costs like
700 pounds so we're gonna see if they
have it and bring it back for him is
this it
Giuseppe no it looks like okay we're
gonna find it it's apparently pretty
close $700 $800 $800 for pair of shoes I
think we'll see we'll see if we can find
it it's crazy to me but people need what
they need doing it best to help
[Music]
this is the star Christian something
Christian laughs okay all right let's go
all right so he sent us to the woman's
store Thank You Man
that was much appreciated and they did a
search for his shoe this $800 shoe and
they don't actually have it anywhere
they don't think so we're gonna go to
Harrods which is a high-end department
store here in London one of the oldest
department stores maybe the oldest part
is store in London and they apparently
have this brand in the basement but
probably not this shoe so we'll check it
out we'll see what happens I hate
wasting time we're on vacation so we're
gonna go to Harrods anyway and now we
have a story so the next time we see
this guy give him a hard time
do your work do your homework before you
send us on a wild goose chase man Oh
Nina Nina Nina is having a bit of a
clumsy day we love you Nina say leave
some positivity in the comments for Nina
that she doesn't get hurt
in a major way or any other minor way
either that's the end it's into the
hurting okay watch out to subscribe to
Harrods
[Music]
we found the place but they're totally
sold out of the boot so he is messaging
him to try to find if he wants us to buy
anything or not let's see that one's
even more great listen we have an 800
pound budget for these boots all right
we didn't quite get them
we got something close well you can't
see it was it was 700 pounds instead
yeah crazy similar to pounds for pair of
shoes
anyway we got them we got them so if we
want the hundred and fifteen pounds of
packs back we have to go to the airport
Tony Tony you owe
Nina a massive dinner and thank you and
foot massages
you want Tony foot massage Tony anyway
it's out of love Nina come on it's out
of love helping somebody out helps
somebody out today believe nation you
could feel my immense satisfaction all
right let's look around and then get out
of here my hair is all over that my mess
guys I'm gonna reward myself I'm gonna
celebrate myself and get a Frappuccino
Nina you're gonna celebrate yourself
with a drink tea Nina celebrating
herself with the tea I'm gonna get a
cappuccino because we are good team
[Music]
what happened Nina
[Music]
are we getting it well we haven't bought
anything for ourselves here so if it's
so pretty why don't you just get it huh
just get it Nina decisions decisions
these are the tough decisions of life do
I buy the pink Starbucks I'm Clara not
[Music]
check out the what crazy mundus pumpkin
spice that patina pretty good and Nina
got her chamomile tea and we also bought
that little pink tumbler for her because
what that was pink okay purple we also
bought that little cute special purple
tumbler for her because Nina's cute and
deserves it right we need to celebrate
after that shoe experience all right we
have our treats on with the day Cheers
[Music]
nina has a question for you Londoners
how can they sit in traffic like this
how can you sit in traffic like this
Londoners we got Londoners watching this
video leave a comment how do you manage
to sit in this traffic let us know leave
it down below that's a good one word up
they're honest burgers I like it we
thought we were done with the rain it's
supposed to be done they bring them
relics oh we're hiding out under uh what
is this waiting for the rain to stop
we're going to go to the supermarket get
some snacks and water
give me a hustle all right we're buying
some Doritos some water
what's that drink you got there
margaritas
one more with this cheddar cheese
we've got some serious snacking to do
all right Nina's gonna try the KitKat
chocolate peanut butter
she gotta take a bigger bite only you
got any peanut butter there
so good you don't like peanut butter oh
you got it for me how is it is it good
all right I'm gonna finish it check it
out guys the bus stops USB charging
stations
go London what are you doing Nina
checking the temperature checking the
rain sooner rain
what's the percent
low percents
it's pretty cool
[Music]
it's been the chip of rain the chip of
rain the chip of rain so next stop for
us is a Portobello market where look at
that that's cool that bar has been
tainted
anyway put it on the market since I have
lots of different people selling their
stuff and supposed to be a vibrant area
I don't think I've ever been any time
I've come to London so I'm excited to
check it out single store but a lot of
these places are closed
cut that lead it's like 6 o'clock close
down early 6 huh
Portobello market bit of a letdown
well Portobello market down we're gonna
go to uh what dinner time dinner time at
a famous London restaurant traditional
food you know loves that stuff let's go
check it in
all right we found it here foot road it
does not look open it kind of looks open
can we go in try yeah no they just
opened up at 6:00 so we were not screwed
out of our dinner
we're the first ones here at the
restaurant boom
[Music]
that was it my mouth is watering oh my
god I want to eat that one right now the
cream looks insane that's low-fat cream
guy that's like only 10 calories and all
that cream there is another that is
insane
how is it
all right we just finished dinner how do
you feel Nina it's really good really
good food not crazy expensive everything
had awesome flavor to it wasn't really
busy though
I was surprised I got a lot of great
reviews and the food was all gonna go
this way
the food was awesome and I thought we
might not get a seat to him I have to
wait we're going to we're gonna do what
we're gonna walk we're gonna walk we're
gonna probably gonna walk back to our
place gonna take us maybe 45 minutes
walk off that food it's a little cold
but you know what your little heat
engine okay Nina the heat engine it's a
new nickname Nina and the heat engine
and h-e Carmichael
okay Nina the heat engine Carmichael
that's gonna stick we're gonna make a
t-shirt we're gonna walk you're gonna
walk back to our place relax maybe open
up a bag of Doritos watch them we can't
watch TV but watch some YouTube and
enjoy
[Music]
we lost Nina to the Moodle Moodle we
just ate a huge me it's a corner MZ what
is he doing there you want to come back
to noodle noodle you want to go in you
want to have something you want some
noodles
no okay I'm full I had all those creamy
desserts one of the things I love about
London it always tells you where to look
at the bottom every Street look right so
you don't get hit by a bus super helpful
all right it's coming up on midnight we
had a relaxing evening I almost know I
ate an entire bag of Doritos an entire
bag of Doritos Nina had half we had some
champagne we watch them I thought you
were sleeping
Nina had three quarters of a bag of
Doritos we watch some agents of shield
and that's it relaxing evening good stay
in tomorrow we're gonna wake up again
one last day in London and I'll lock it
and you guys will see it next week thank
you for joining me again on this journey
I hope you had an amazing weekend I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love guys I'll see you
soon